all right y'all time for my first guest
he's a country music
legend he's had 10 number one albums and
sold over 50 million records all around
the world
he's back now with his first solo album
in half a decade
it's called here on earth you gotta
check it out tim mcgraw get on in here
hey did i get it working yes you did
congratulations well done
i am so technically unsavvy it's
unbelievable
oh my gosh me too i'm this is not my
forte
whatsoever um how are you how have you
all been in quarantine
doing well i mean you know it's i get
bored pretty quickly and pretty easily
but other than that
it's it's been good watching a lot of
movies cooking a lot
um we're lucky we have all all three of
our daughters are at home right now so
we've had
had them home for like a week so it's
good to spend some time with those guys
you know you know it's been a tough year
for everybody we've had two graduations
this year and you know they've been
a little odd and a little different but
you know you're trying to make the best
out of everything
it kind of stinks too though when you're
graduate because i know one graduated
college and one graduated high school
right
yes one graduate our youngest graduate
in high school when our middle girl
graduated college yes
yeah that's kind of a bummer you work so
hard especially the college kid and then
you're like okay cool
like no celebration none at all for sure
i mean we had some like social distances
and some zoom kind of thing celebrations
and and here at the house we had
an outdoor just our immediate family you
know our kids and
my sister and her kids so and
everybody's been tested and so we did
the whole
we did it all right but we stayed away
from each other sort of sit high across
the yard at each other
that's good i feel like everybody has
their little pod you know that everybody
you don't go outside of it then you all
should be be good um
well i i hear that faith put you to work
in the garden are you cooking
are you cooking with the stuff you're
growing no no i was doing some flowers
for because oh flowers
yeah because our two of our girls were
driving home
you know nobody's flying really so they
were driving in from california
to just to be home for a little while
and so
faith wanted me to redo the front door
and all
and do flowers all around the place so i
spent a couple of days doing some
gardening
trying to try to make it look nicer are
you that guy that kind of gets out there
and you can do that pretty easily
i mean i if i have all the equipment
there and all the stuff picked out and
i'm told what to do then i can do it but
if i have to come up with too much on my
own then i'm not very good but
when i was in high school my mom's
pretty pretty artistic and
has a green thumb i always worked with
plants and stuff so when i was in high
school
i spent a lot of time working out of
plant nursery mostly just hauling stuff
you know but
but i spent a lot of time doing some
yard work and
and you know that kind of thing
landscaping i feel like foliage i feel
like it can just
change the landscape in such a beautiful
way and like make it so pretty and
calming and
yeah it's i'm the same way so which
daughter is this so singing with the dog
oh my god it's so cute which daughter is
that
that's maggie that's the middle daughter
yeah and uh
stromboli's the dog's name yeah very
italian i like it yeah well he's he's a
he's just a he's he's a glorified bird
dogs all he is but he's italian
caught i think he's called an italian
bronco so we had a family of those dogs
he's the last one left well we have one
more at the farm but but uh
so we name them all italian names i love
that y'all are both singers and even
your dog sing that's awesome
it really is in the family be fair
stromboli's thing's a lot better than me
i'm probably the worst singer in the
house
oh shut up i've seen you live that's
what i found so funny
i've seen you live you and faith and you
came backstage and you were like oh man
if i know how to sing better i was like
you did an
awesome job of singing along i was like
y'all both killed it
like you're so humble whatever he has
just released his first album in five
years it's called here on earth so tim
when did you actually finish the album
i hear you tinkered all the way till the
end right yeah i mean
look as you know are you ever really
finished with
making a record i mean you sort of get
it in the barrel right you know
because you can always then you go back
a year later and you hear something hey
i wish i would have fixed that or i wish
i'd
did that a little different it's always
you're always art's always a work in
progress never finished with it but
yeah i've been working on it gosh has
been faith in you know faith and i did
our soul to soul tour a couple years we
we made our on our first do add
something so this is the first
solo album in five years that i've done
but i worked on it
like the la the last part of our solar
sold tours
when i started working on it i spent a
lot of time flying in and out
from from on being on the road and
spending the night in the studio working
on it and
yeah we tweaked it and worked on it and
uh kept messing with
sounds and messing with mixes up until
the last minute until it just finally
had to be turned in
yeah no i'm the same way i think they're
all like for artists it's like your
little babies and then
you go out on the road tour with it like
you said and you get out there you're
like
oh you start doing something live you're
like i wish i had done that in the
studio
but so this album is called here on
earth um and it's about the meaning of
life
which is awesome because i literally
have an album called meeting live um but
has that
that changed which i didn't find it by
the way um but has that changed
for for you this year like what life is
i feel like all of us have been put in
this
situation like literally every human on
the planet has been put in this like
quarantine kind of pandemic mode and
there's just so many challenges that
we're being faced with right now and
also like uh bringing
back family to kind of those simple kind
of forms and and us not being able to be
as busy most of us
like is that do you think that kind of
affected you with this yeah for sure did
you know
it all came together you know post
we were working on the pre-pandemic i
guess but but
a lot of the songs started making more
sense
contextually yeah um after after we
after the pandemic started happening we
were in the middle of mixing and we
remixed a few things after it all
happened just because we thought it just
needed a different emotional pull to it
because of the things that were going on
and what i wanted to do with this record
from the beginning what i started out
doing was just sort of
i wanted to create i didn't want to do
sort of a linear story or anything like
that or do any kind of concept album
but i did want to sort of lay out a
tapestry of life
in a lot of ways and have each song sort
of reflect these vignettes
that are part of your life and as you go
through life as you mature
from time to the things that you did as
teenagers to the things that you did
who was an older adult there's even a
song about losing your dog
you know on this outside i love it
i know so it's just you know it's it's
just about it's about the things that we
go through in life and
certainly now is a very reflective time
in a lot of ways because of the
what we're all going through and what
we're all dealing with and um
there's you know certainly people are
going through some terrible times with
it but uh
but also i think there is a reconnection
with family and reconnecting with your
kids and a reconnection with
with being at home and and sort of
learning more about each other and
paying more attention to each other and
being a little bit more
respectful of each other's space because
of the sort of the world we're living in
now
yeah i mean perspective is definitely i
think the word for 2020.
um so i mean in 2020 i mean it's been a
tough year obviously
we've been talking about it but it's
been a tough year for country music too
we've lost a few legends
um one of those was actually um kenny
rogers i know that was an idol of yours
right
for sure kenny rogers was a big guy with
my arm
and such a nice guy and i got to sing
with him you know it was which was
really incredible the funniest memory i
have a kenny roger a couple of memories
i have a kenny rogers but
he came to one of my shows and he was
saying she believes in me together and
he came to one of those shows and
and it was one of those soul shows where
we had our stage was in the round and
then the center and the only way to get
out to the stage was to be in some sort
of road case or
so we're trying to get kenny rogers out
under the stage to do this song with me
so
he gets into a laundry hamper so imagine
kenny rogers getting took me into a
laundry hamper and laying down
and covering him up and rolling him out
under the stage and him coming up and
doing she believes in me which was
really a special moment for me and
another kenny rogers memory i have is
he played the monroe civic center and my
mom was a huge kenny rogers fan
and so she took me out of school that
morning i think i was in the sixth grade
seventh grade or something like that she
took me out of school that morning
i got put me in line at the monroe civic
center and i made it all the way
to the window before it sold out and i
didn't get to get tickets
so but later on i was in college and i
was working selling popcorn at the
monroe civic center and i got to see
kenny rogers concert selling popcorn
oh my gosh that's so i've sold popcorn
too in a movie theater um
all our previous jobs um but wait before
we go i i want to ask about some rad
cowboy skills that i saw
um so who taught you how to rope oh well
i uh i grew up riding i could i mean my
whole life
my stepdad was a cowboy and
spent a lot of time on horses guys
that's funny i i could ride and rope
before i could walk practically so i
spent a lot of time doing that and i
spent some time in high school rodeo
when i was a kid
wrote some bareback horses and some team
roping some calf roping so
i've done a little bit of that in my
life for sure it's so great to see you
again tim please tell your lovely family
i say hello
and y'all be sure to check out tim's new
album it's called here on earth
[Music]
you